on les remet en latin il nous manque
énormément
même après 10 ans les parents de david
fortin espère toujours
il rêve de revoir leur fils disparu le
10 février 2009
ce matin là david qui était victime
d'intimidation à l'école devait se
rendre à pied à l'arrêt d'autobus
ses parents ne l'ont jamais revue tout a
changé il a fallu réapprendre à se faire
une nouvelle vie sans la présence
physique de david mais david est
toujours présente dans notre cas une
absence très lourde à porter en tout
début de disparition les médias sont
beaucoup présent aussi ni les bénévoles
sont très actifs font du porte-à-porte
vont afficher les photos
mais à mesure que si l'enfant n'est pas
retrouvé tout le monde tous ces gens
vaut tourner vers leur vie normale et la
famille se retrouve tout seul au canada
chaque année les corps policiers
reçoivent entre 30000 et 50000
signalements d'enfants disparus
neuf fois sur dix on les retrouve en
moins de 7 jours
mais pour les autres les enquêtes ces
tirs c'est pourquoi cette semaine la grc
a décidé de mettre l'accent sur 45
dossiers en vue de la journée nationale
des enfants disparus
on veut aussi encourager les gens la
population qui aurait peut-être des
informations à nous partager consonance
école à certains cokydal même des années
50 des années 60 qui ne sont pas oubliés
comme diane carier disparu à l'âge de 6
ans 1963 mélina martin 13 ans disparu à
farnham en 2005 et sans oublier ariel
jefferies kouakou dont on n'a toujours
pas de trace après un an malgré le temps
qui passe les autorités reçoivent encore
des indices on sent que les gens sont
encore à l'affût à avoir les policiers
on a soit un garçon à peine à souder des
messages une épreuve encore difficile
pour les parents de david fortin qui
sont demeurés soudée malgré l'adversité
au mac os j'ai pas choisi d'être ici
marie josée paquet comme radio canada
montréal est